[Musique]
j'ai ma carrière j'ai vaincu les câbles
parce que tu m'avais je pense déjà le
couvert titre est celui que j'avais 5
ans
je prends geojit d'augmenter le bailleur
les couvertures qui couvre de honte y
est plus que j'avais 11 ans lorsque
j'étais très jeune je n'ai jamais été un
échec sur le sujet de montréjeau car que
pourrait en demander non consensuelle
mais une fois que j'étais présager les
gens me demandaient des choses comme
attendu longtemps déjà y at il des
cheveux par bus
bien sûr cela est prévu étendue du cdn
seul guichet mon école qui enchantait en
7e année
quand j'ai annoncé à ma mère que je
voulais porter des bailleurs elle m'a
demandé si ces j'ai pris ce que je
voulais faire
et si jeudi sur ce choix je lui dis qu
il met à l'épreuve
mais pour ça les étudiants les mes amis
tout le monde mais t'aimerais pourquoi
je vais fait ce choix et pour quelles
raisons c'est ce que j'ai décidé de
porter sur la balle
c'était très étonnant que tous ceux qui
m'entouraient y avait supposé que
j'étais forcément non seulement les gens
à l'école mais aussi même pas qu'on file
maker disait que j'étais trop jeune
gracq décision et ma mère me questionner
sur si je savais ce que je faisais mes
intentions étaient toujours en calcium
lorsque j'ai porté mon job est même
aujourd'hui
parfois ils jouent qu'une frustrant
parce que chrome toi j'ai aussi le droit
de me présenter de la manière je choisis
il y avait je suis allé chez le notaire
là je lui demandais la façon dont la
santé a fêté mon avenir
la première chose qui est sorti de sa
bouche et si c'est un peu comme toi
aussi d'aller à l'université
tu sais ma phrase la façon dont tu es et
la façon dont tu te présentes
et puis il a continué j'étais en show
city shop week-end français je suis
obligé de me priver d'une éducation tout
simplement que je porte une vision
encore plus aiguë ans s'est excusé
morizet et nous sommes en train de créer
une professionnelle un doctorat c'est
lui qui me décourageait lui 5 6 8 6 vous
direz peut-être ce qui m'est arrivé
l'anacr à tous les jours mais et c'est
la vérité
suis je sais de la société qui fait face
à la discrimination
suis-je le seul à la société qui fait
face à l'usm rugby au sexy
prenons l'exemple de miuccia go et une
femme musulmane qui a perdu sous la
couverture d'une vue populaire est
immédiatement et devenus des sujets de
controverse
mais pourquoi devons-nous jugé à base de
ces familles et l'ong face aux insultes
pourquoi devons nous les crânes utiliser
en fonction de ce qu'elle propre et non
pas de ce qu'elle est bien sûr le droit
social même mais pourquoi tourner ou
d'un titre phare musulmane american tuto
retire son propre titre journalistes
pourquoi est elle jugée à base de ces
familles est une empreinte entre les
directeurs aux voiles à la femme qui
porte une chemise 2 lé nouveau visage de
sauvegarde il est plus facile de dire ah
oui nous devons arrêter de caractériser
les fameuses semaine mais cela ne fera
rien
après remettre aux gens de gaza devrait
juger pour eux-mêmes
donc la même façon qu arrêter
complètement la stigmatisation serait
d'arrêter d'accepter les uns les autres
sur la base du site universitaire me
voir une fameuse m'emporter
ou ce dont je suis et non ce dont je
porte le quart utilisé à la façon dont
le mari et la façon dont je me présente
ne me semble pas juste en me donnant un
total vous mais diminué comme être
humain il y à 1,6 milliard de musulmans
dans le monde et ce d'après la deuxième
religion du sort dans ton propre nation
plus rapidement dans le monde nous les
femmes visage bienvenus
par conséquent nous devrions être traité
comme tous les autres personnes écoutant
le droit d'une étiquette et je me crame
utilisé en meetic hâtez vous donnez
l'impression que mon futur défilé qui je
suis vous nourrissez les serrures type
qui ne manqueront pas les mêmes droits
les mêmes progression les mêmes
l'expérience que tous les autres arrêtez
de me canaliser abbas ce dont je prends
ce n'est pas juste c'est la
discrimination
un front froid sur l'événement et pour
vous mettre à l'aise
j'aimerais vous dire je ne dois pas un
mauvais au monde up et bien sûr j'y ai
de cheveux
[Applaudissements]